in the meantime jobs in general are hard
to come by right now and a virtual job
fair this morning connected people with
companies hiring right now here in the
valley our hector mejia
live with us this afternoon with those
details hi hector
hey there and more than a thousand
people signed up for this job fair was
actually supposed to be held in person
but that had to change because of the
pandemic
and one of the groups behind this job
fair is one stop career center here
right behind us
we have a list of the companies that
were featured earlier today in case you
want to write those down they're all in
the henderson area
companies amazon barclays marksman
security and rdi
plus henderson police and the city's
parks and recreation department
they're also hiring it's like a big
collaboration between city county and
state agencies to coordinate this
virtual job fair
as many as 14-hundred people
pre-registered
county commissioner jim gibson says the
need is as clear as
day as the state's major employers are
forced
to reopen slowly because of the pandemic
nevada's unemployment rate
has reached record highs
people are getting nervous unemployment
benefits are
changing as we speak and
people need opportunity they need hope
uh they need a job they need income
and these job fairs in my estimation
constitute a real lifeline for people
we're told employers have been fielding
questions throughout the day
talking with potential new hires they
were given a link to
go online and fill out an application if
you missed this virtual
job fair you did not miss out completely
you can still reach out to those
employers and fill out
an application online reporting near
charleston and torrey pines hector mejia
8 news now all right thank you hector
and if you are looking for a job right
now we've put together a list
and links to apply you can find it on
our website 8newsnow.com